there's a really interesting inflection
point
where folks start asking themselves wait
a minute
so is it really going to be 20
online penetration in e-commerce for
groceries or maybe it's going to be 50
and if it's 50 it's going to stay 50
maybe it's gonna be 80
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders i'm so
incredibly excited for this episode i've
been following this company for so long
i actually visited their offices a
couple times
and really what they're doing is just
revolutionary and we're just gonna
continue hearing about them for so long
meet elgam goren the co-founder and ceo
of fabric
the leader in automated micro
fulfillment centers
fabric partners with grocers and
retailers to transform underutilized
space into robotics powered warehouses
that fulfill online orders in under 5
minutes
he has led the company from its
inception in 2015 through its first
deployments and now
is at the helm of its rapidly scaling
operations before co-founding fabric
l-ram served as a major in the israel
defense forces managing r d teams and
multi-disciplinary operations in the
intelligence technology unit
el-ram holds a bachelor of science in
physics and electrical engineering from
the technion israel institute of
technology
and an mba from tel aviv university el
ram goren welcome to 20 minute leaders
fabric one of my favorite companies in
the world i swear to god how are you
doing
i'm doing well and thank you for having
us and thank you for having me
i i've been following for so long uh
talking
uh for many many times with with draw
berman and one of the investors and and
visiting the offices and thinking
critically about how
fabric is is changing the way that we
think about
fulfillment and microfilm and and
robotics and the future of
of of warehouses and and it's really
really exciting i'm already
scared that i'm not going to get through
all the things i want to talk about in
these 20 minutes
so all around very briefly before we get
to talk about micro fulfillment
tell me about yourself how do you find
yourself the co-founder and ceo
of a robotics company
well um so i'm in my background i'm
actually
trained as a i studied electrical
engineering and physics
uh back in uh in israel here at carnegie
mellon here in the us
uh and after school i um
i joined the idf uh spent there about 10
years
in one of the tech units there and that
was before we we started what was then
called
uh common sense robotics and today uh
fabric so that's that's kind of
in short my background so obviously from
the tech side
uh but in time we kind of uh fell in
love with this uh this field we're in
and uh looking forward to spending some
time on that
with you today so you know when i think
of micro fulfillment and the problems
that we're facing with warehouses you
know i think of costco i think of
walmart of amazon these
i'm thinking of you know huge huge
populations that need the need solutions
and here
in israel we we have one of the most
innovative companies in the field
what makes you think of microfulfillment
as a problem that that is worth tackling
from where we are
well i think that's a great question so
you mentioned a few things in
in in kind of the last minute or two and
one was robotics and the other was
uh you know warehousing and supply
chains and things like that but
for us um as founders we actually did
not come from retail
we didn't come from supply chain and we
didn't come from logistics so we had no
idea uh about the
you know the depth and complexities of
some of the problems that we would
eventually face
but and so the way we were thinking
about this is actually from a consumer
standpoint
so fabric was born from a consumer need
uh basically to get your groceries
faster and cheaper than going to the
supermarket that's how we start
and that's what we wanted to solve and
that's what we set out to do
in time that evolved into hey
how do i create the tools and services
that would allow my
you know favorite brands or retailers to
offer me as a consumer
these types of on-demand experiences and
why is it that they
can't offer that today and that's
exactly what
fabric is doing today so fabric was born
from a consumer mindset of
that's the type of experience that we
would want to
have as consumers but at the same time
we looked at the industry and said okay
so
what would it take for those businesses
to offer those types of experiences and
and mainly
why is it that they can't or won't do
that
today and solving those those
problems those challenges is what we do
today
and that's how micro fulfillment was
born right so everything you're going to
see in fabric whether it's
you know the algo or the data or the
software or the robots or the real
estate
it's all it all comes down to how do we
get to
a solution that allows those businesses
to create
those experiences to the consumers
who at the end of the day are you and me
amazing and so take me take me a little
bit back and 30 000 feet in the air
why can't our favorite brands give us
the on demand experience that we really
really want
it's 20 21 right so the answer is that
they can
but they can't do it while running a
sustainable business
and that's something that uh that's
something that
some companies can't afford to do
meaning
to lose money on their business on every
order
and some businesses can't and in time
you know
once you scale it's becoming more and
more challenging to do that because
you're
literally losing more and more money as
you grow your business
and that's not a great business model
um and so um
and so the reason they can't do that
isn't because
you know there isn't the instacart or
the postmates
or you know whatever platform that's
already available today to make that
happen
the reason is that at the end of the day
retailers and brands need to choose
between
an on-demand experience that will allow
them to
compete and a
kind of a negative or an unsustainable
unit economics
type of model or not being able to
compete
and running their their existing
business model
and what we're here to do is basically
to combine
the best of both worlds um and more than
happy obviously to to kind of to get
into the details of why that's not
that combination is not available today
um and at the at the heart of it is that
in order to allow for speed you really
need proximity right you really need to
be close to your end customers and
i think that's you know that's almost
um uh almost straightforward it's not
always straightforward but but
let's assume we're uh we're accepting
that
that assumption up
at the same time the closer you get
to your customers it it is actually
more and more challenging to run
an efficient business because everything
that we know
or that the industry learned about
supply chains is that
the more you consolidate right the more
you make your operations more
centralized
that's how to you know to drive more
efficiency
so if you're starting from an operation
like
online groceries in 2015 2016
all the way to today or general
e-commerce for that matter
going closer only gets
only makes the situation worse from unit
economics perspective
interesting and at the same time the
starting point for a lot of these
businesses
is that they're already losing on their
ecommerce business and that's
especially true for for online grocery
so when we came and said
you actually need to go against
economies of scale
for for very good reasons a lot of
people laughed
because it doesn't really make sense the
only way it does make sense
is if you you're able to inject
a new type of model a new architecture
uh or a new stack of tech that allows
that
to to make sense you're effectively what
we're effectively today doing is kind of
changing the game from a game of
economies of scale
to a game of economies of density and
once you have that density
uh and that's already available in
online groceries for example and we're
seeing that in health and beauty as well
once you have that
it actually does make sense and that's
what we're seeing uh
in israel with the super farm we were
just announced a kind of
an extension of of the operation to
kind of to uh to cover their entire
business their e-commerce business
and that's what we're seeing here in the
us as well
incredible and and how do robots play a
part of this how does it
how does deep technology impact the way
that you're able to
supply this microphone right no that's a
great question so
let's take one step back and say okay so
you need to get closer but you also need
to be a lot more efficient so how do you
do that so
right uh you need to be able to utilize
low-cost real estate uh you need to be
able to
generate a lot of throughput in small
footprints
and you need to be able to uh be much
more efficient
in terms of your operating costs for
this to make for this to make sense
as it happens um you know robots are
really good
in two things uh they're really good in
um
in being efficient in space if you
design it the right way and so if you if
you enter one of our facilities you
would
notice very very early on
that it's basically a 3d cube uh
where we store things and so we can
shrink
the size of the facility uh quite
significantly
and and actually increases the
throughput per square foot inch or per
square meter
uh which is a is a key metric for the
business
and at the same time as it happens
robots
drive labor efficiency right so um
if you're able to um
transition uh from a operation that's
very labor-intensive
to one where people still
are an important piece of the operation
but they're really focused on the things
that people
are very good at and most of the work is
being done by robots
then you're able to create that
arbitrage as well and the combination of
those two
basically allows us to create this new
operating point in the
in the p l of the business that we're
serving
that allows again to combine what we
wanted
in the first place which is speed
and efficiency and that's kind of the
name of the game
right and so as you're as you're
building these these warehouses and as
you're as you're thinking through these
technologies how do you go and explain
this to
the regular retailers you know they is
it is a
common sense thing for them to
understand okay this is the natural
progression of how
the warehouses are going to move to
whether it's supermarkets super
farm or or traditional retailers or is
this or does this require a little bit
more explainability
well i i wish i could tell you that the
person who's speaking to you
is a great um speaker
uh and a great marketer but i'm not
gonna i'm gonna i'm not gonna choose
that path because i'm not sure that's
necessarily
the case here i think that
it's a combination of three things it's
a combination obviously a vision
and kind of a vision that actually makes
sense
um at least given certain
circumstances it's a combination
of um early adopters
that are visionaries so i will i will
tell you right now
if if if we went with
you know everything that we have right
now which is a lot more than we had five
years ago
and we would pitch this uh in 2016 most
retailers would not buy it
interesting because it
you know there are certain companies i
i'm not sure we're definitely not the
only ones but
i don't think there are a lot of these
companies that
um that undermine
some um
very basic assumptions how entire
industries work
uh you know i think you know tesla is a
good example for that and spacex is
definitely a good example to that and
i'm not i'm not we're i'm definitely not
putting us uh in the same
in the same league but conceptually
if you're going to go and tell retailers
that everything that they've thought
of in terms of um consolidation
is actually the wrong direction because
consumers are going for on demand
and technology will allow that to be
sustainable
you shouldn't expect um
you know um you shouldn't expect
90 conversion on day one
and the reason is that it's
it is it is somewhat it is somewhat
different
and most people it well put it this
differently
there are a few people that will go with
that vision
and you know these are the early early
adopters and
they're the the greatest champions and
that's everything that you need
once you have those and you're
successful with showing that that
actually works then you're going to see
uh more adoption and i wouldn't even
tell you that today
you'll have 100 adoption rates but it's
definitely very different than what was
a few years ago third element
is luck so um
you know we when we started the company
i wish i could tell you that we could
predict
in 2016 that a year later amazon would
will acquire whole foods and and walmart
will acquire
you know a bit later would acquire jazz
uh and that covid would accelerate
everything that we know of in e-commerce
um
and i wouldn't i i wouldn't i would
definitely not call
covid um a lucky
um kind of event for anyone
uh but from a business perspective it
definitely kind of shifted a lot of
things
and so there is an element of just being
in the right place at the right time
just you know you can't you can't run
away from that
uh you just need to be able to um
to leverage that to accelerate right to
the company
a hundred percent now if we're if we're
imagining the world
you know a few years time i'm i'm always
curious about the impact and and you
know the impact has a butterfly effect
obviously
and it's not just this idea of being
able of providing retailers with the
ability to provide
on-demand services and that are actually
you know
cost-effective for the business but but
how does the world look
in your eyes even just in a few years
how does how does you know micro
fulfillment work in the world
i'm guessing that we're going to be
seeing a lot more fulfillment happening
from
inner cities right a lot of you we're
going to see things moving closer to the
people rather than big warehouses
outside
yeah well i think that you know it
depends on how far
you want to look at right um i think
that in the
you know retail is pretty broad but if
we if we
focus on that for just one second i
think there is an opportunity here
not just to um
to be more efficient and to create to
create
kind of more or an elevated type of
experience
there is really an opportunity here to
create a
what what i i'd refer to as a superior
retail model
meaning you could and i think that the
world is is going that direction
uh regardless of fabric where
um you will you'll end up at a point
where it's
more um it's more convenient for a
consumer
to order online uh it's gonna get it's
gonna be faster than going to the store
it's gonna be cheaper than going to the
store and they're gonna have more
selection
and at the same time and this will take
time but
i'm i'm a big believer that that's
that's that's going to happen
the side of the retailer would also
uh see a better model meaning
it's gonna be more profitable for
retailers
to run online operations
than it is to run a store and that's not
necessarily that's not the case today
for most people it's very far from being
the case today
but i believe technology and these kind
of
novel uh operating models and
architectures will allow us to get there
and once that
happens there's a really interesting
inflection point
where folks start asking themselves wait
a minute
so is it really going to be 20
online penetration in e-commerce for
groceries or maybe it's going to be 50
and if it's 50 it's going to stay 50
maybe it's going to be 80
and so there i think you know the next
few years i'm not sure if it's
you know five years or 10 years things
are going to get very interesting
i think the beauty of it is that is that
it's really up to the industry right
uh because there is room to get there
um it's just a function of you know
uh is is tech in the in the mature place
that it needs to be
uh it also is a function of you know
uh new new players that are entering the
market
from the retailer side like gopa for
gorillaz or instacart or uber that we're
we're seeing
they're they're moving up they're
creating a big dent
into more traditional industries and i
think they're gonna
they're gonna have even a bigger dent
than what we're seeing today
uh the world is changing fast uh i often
sit
on the roof and i and i look at tel aviv
and i'm looking at you know the
thousands of scooters going by and i'm
looking at the small businesses
and i'm looking at the small
supermarkets and the large supermarkets
and and i can't help but get excited by
by the idea of how many things are going
to be shifting
in the next few years just be below our
eyes
and and i think it's a it's honestly one
of the most incredible
times to to think through these things
and and i can't wait to see where things
are headed and i'm so honored to be
speaking to one of the people that are
that are making it happen and they're
and are going to be a part of this
of this incredible revolution and
evolution so el
thank you very very much i have a few
more questions for you very short ones
but but they are important
and i want to take you back to your
childhood what fascinated you as a kid
perhaps a a passion hobby or your
favorite subject in school
i loved math i still love math
i i i'm gonna i'm gonna be a bit nerdy
now but
uh it's
i i found it to be so beautiful as a
the the concept there you know not not
trying to kind of to
be too too romantic about it but i just
love
math and i know that's true you know
terribly nerdy but
that's uh that's the honest truth
i'm right there with you and um perhaps
a role model or some figure of
inspiration along your journey
uh professionally or personally a real
or fake
something that you know inspired you as
you have been on your journey
um that's a great question
[Music]
um
i'm going to go with th there you know
there there could be
there there is a classical answer to
your question which is probably
um perhaps steve jobs
or you know one of those figures and
that's definitely
that's definitely there um
[Music]
i'd go with uh i'd go with my parents
uh i need a small explanation at least
something
i think i think you know almost each and
every one of us
will will understand uh we'll understand
but
um we're we just have
we have two wonderful young boys and uh
kind of seeing them grow up and seeing
how much uh
how much goes into
that uh kind of uh period of time
uh and uh especially their you know
their mother and the love and care that
uh that they're receiving uh just
reflects on uh
you know the earlier generation so i'm
gonna go with uh with parents
and especially moms i love it
and three words you would use to
describe yourself
um that's a good one um
so i haven't had a lot of kind of we've
we've chatted before that so i i didn't
i didn't prepare an answer
no commitments at all but uh let's go
with uh let's go with yes we can
i'll take it i'll definitely take it
thank you very very much this was
wonderful thank you for the inspiration
and
both in this show but but for years
before that uh
stay safe and stay healthy and and i
can't wait to see you know what fabric
does to the world
[Music]
you